[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم ال سيئه
بعاصي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه اللقطات من العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس وفيها مشهد لم يتوقف منذ
الصباح اطلقت عليهم نقابات اسم الخميس
الاسود والذي بدا باضرابات وتظاهرات سرعان
ما تحولت الى مواجهات بين الشرطه
والمحتاجين
ومن مكه المكرمه تريدنا هذه الصور اجواء
الحرم المكي في اول ايام شهر رمضان
المبارك
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
بالتزامن مع تاكيد مسؤول امريكي للجزيره
قرار تحريك مقاتلات متطوره من الشرق
الاوسط الى اوروبا واسيا
يقول ان علم ما بعد الحرب البارده انتهى
وان منافسه تجري لرسم المرحله المقبله
والبنتاجون يصف زياره شيجن بينج لموسكو من
اشاره مقلقه ويقول ان بيجين بات التحدي
المتسارعا وفي رد المقابل يقول ان العقد
المقبل لن يكون هادئا وان هناك دولا لا
تفهم الا لغه القوه
في مشهد الحرب المستمره في اوكرانيا معارك
متواصله في باخموت والبنتاجون يتحدث عن
تشكيل فريق للتاكد من تسريع عمليه تسليم
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا وتزويدها بالقدرات
اللازمه تسلم عشرات دبابات اثنين
وسلوفاكيا تقدم اربع مقاتلات ميج تسعه
وعشرين
مع ارتفاع وتيره الاحتجاجات ضد الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الكنيست يصادق على قانون يضيق
فرص عزل رئيس الحكومه ويمنحون ثنياهو
الحصانه رئيس الشباب يصف الوضع بالخطير
للغايه مع استمرار الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
ونتنياهو يقول انه عازم على المضي قدما في
الاصلاحات القضائيه
[تصفيق]
مع اصرار الحكومه الفرنسيه على تنفيذ
قانون التقاعد الجديد اضرابات الخميس
الاسود تشل قطاعات النقل والطيران والطاقه
وبالتزامن مع مواجهات بين الشرطه
والمتظاهرين في شوارع باريس ماكرون يدعو
النقابات للحوار ويحذر من العنف
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا الازمات المتزايده في وجه
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو في ظل الاحتجاجات
الرافضه للتعديلات القضائيه اخر هذه
المظاهر الاحتجاجيه كان توجه الالاف من
المحتاجين الى منطقه بني براك التي يقطنها
مستوطنون يمينيون وهما يرشح المشهد لمزيد
من الصدام تتزامن الاحتجاجات مع مصادقه
الكنيسه اليوم على مشروع قانون يشدد من
شروط عزل رئيس الحكومه من منصبه وهو ما
يمنح بالتالي الحصانه لبنيامين نتنياهو
الذي يحاكم بتهم فساد وخيانه الامانه
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي ما هو مصير ائتلاف
حكومه نتنياهو امام سيل الاحتجاجات
المستمره
52% صوت لصالح خيار خيار الائتلاف بينما
قال 18 بالمئه انه سيتم الاستجابه للمطالب
وتجنب الانهيار اما 30% فيرون الا تاثير
لهذه الاحتجاجات على الحكومه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على
الشاشه لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد
يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
عالم ما بعد الحرب البارده ولا بهذه
الجمله صدر وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن كلامه وهو يتحدث عن منافسه شديده
جاريه لتحدي ما سياتي كلام بلينكن جاء في
كلمه امام الكونجرس الامريكي قال فيه بان
واشنطن تريد ان يتشكل عالم حر ومزدهر
والتعبير له
اجتماعنا اليوم ياتي في لحظه فارقه فقد
ولى علم ما بعد الحرب البارده وهناك
منافسه شديده ايجاريه لتحديد ما سياتي بعد
ذلك ولد الولايات المتحده رؤيه ايجابيه
لذلك المستقبل الا وهو عالم حر ومفتوح
وامن ومزدهر
الحديث من واشنطن لم يقتصر على تصريحات
بلنكن فوزير الدفاع الامريكي
وصف زياره الرئيس الصيني لروسيا قبل يومين
بانها حملت اشاره مقلقه للغايه بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده مؤكدا ان الصين تمثل
تحديا متزايدا لبلاده اوستن قال ايضا ان
واشنطن تستثمر في وضع قوه اكثر مرونه
بمنطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وزياده
نطاق التدريبات مع شركائها
ميزانيتنا مدفوعه بالاستراتيجيه وبجديه
منافستنا مع الصين
وستساعدنا هذه الميزانيه على مواصله تنفيذ
استراتيجيه الدفاع الوطني لعام 2022
واستراتيجيه الرئيس للامن القومي لدي الان
ثلاث اولويات رئيسيه في البنتاغون الدفاع
عن امتنا والاعتناء بقواتنا المتميزه
والنجاح من خلال العمل الجماعي والصين
تمثل التحدي المتسارع الذي نواجهه ونحن
نسعى جاهدين لمجارات ذلك التحدي
بالتزامني مع هذا الحديث عن القوه المرنه
اكد مسؤول امريكي للجزيره ان البنتاجون
يخطط لارسال طائرات حربيه من طراز اي 10
الى الشرق الاوسط دون الخوض في عددها او
موعد وصولها الى المنطقه وقال المتحدث
باسم القياده الوسطى للقوات الامريكيه
في تصريح مكتوب للجزيره انه يجري تعزيز
القوات الامريكيه من خلال الشراكات في
عموم الشرق الاوسط اضاف بوتشينو ان
القياده الوسطى تعتمد ايضا على الابتكار
خصوصا فيما يتعلق بالانظمه المسيره وانظمه
الذكاء الاصطناعي
وكانت صحيفه
نقلت عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان الولايات
المتحده ستنقل مقاتلات حديثه من الشرق
الاوسط الى منطقتي اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
واوروبا وبحسب الصحيفه فان الخطوه المقرر
تنفيذها في ابريل نيسان المقبل جزء من خطه
اوسعه تنص على الاحتفاظ بقوات بحريه وبريه
متواضعه في الشرق الاوسط واكد المسؤولون
الامريكيون للصحيفه ان نقل الطائرات الى
اوروبا واسيا ياتي ضمن جهود واشنطن لردع
الصين وروسيا
وفيما يبدو ردا مقابلا قال نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي ديمتري ان السنوات العشر
المقبله لن تكون هادئه بسبب رغبه الغرب في
الهيمنه وراء ان بعض الدول لا تفهم ولا
تستمع الا للغه القوه لذلك لا فائده من
الاتفاق معها كما حذر من ان توقيف الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين في الخارج يعادل
اعلان حرب على روسيا حسب تعبيره
يعني
بشكل مفاجئ يتخذون قرارا بحق الرئيس
الروسي ولنتصور ان رئيس دوله نوويه وصل
الى المانيا وتعرض للتوقيف تكون هذه
الخطوه اعلان حرب على روسيا وفي هذه
الحاله كل وسائلنا من صواريخ وغيرها ستطير
مباشره الى مكتب المستشار الالماني
من باريس سينضم الينا جيم تاونزن نائب
مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق لشؤون
اوروبا والنيتو ومن بيجي معنا رونغه
الاعلامي والباحث السياسي مرحبا بكما سيد
اذا وزير الخارجيه الامريكي يقول ان عالم
ما بعد الحرب البارده قد انتهى هل توافق
الصين على هذه الرؤيه
اهلا ومرحبا بكم
اولا يعني
ترى العالم وضعوا الدولي الان
يتجه في اتجاه الاكثر
تعدديه
متعدده الاكتاب فهناك ليس كما كان بعد حرب
العالم بعد الحرب البارده يعني هناك كتب
واحد معنا الامريكيه فهي يجب ان ندفع
الديمقراطيه العلاقات الدوليه
ويعني ان نتجه الى التعدديه الاقطاب الى
التطور العلاقات الدوليه نحو اكثر العداله
ولذلك
فالسين ايضا فهي القوه
الدافعوا الاتجاه
عالم متعدد الاقطاب وفق الرؤيه الصينيه
ماذا ستفعل الولايات المتحده حيال هذه
النظره من الصين ومن روسيا
اعتقد ان زميلي الصيني محق ان العالم
مختلف تماما عما كان عليه ليس فقط في
اثناء الحرب البارده لكن في عقاب الحرب
البارده ايضا الصين الان قوه عظمى في
العالم وهي قوه اقتصاديه كبرى ايضا ولها
تاثير كبير في منطقه الهندي والهادئ نحن
نامل انه سيكون لدينا علاقات جيده مع
الصين اقتصادياتنا تعتمد على بعضها البعض
وعلى علاقات التجاريه ايضا بالتالي نحن لم
نكن راضين ان نرى خلال سنوات الماضيه
الصين العدائيه في منطقه الهندي والهادئ
نرغب ان تكون هنالك صين غير عدائيه الصين
تركز على تطوير العلاقات الاقتصاديه
والتجاريه وتطوير العلاقات لكن لا يبدو ان
هذا هو اتجاه الصين حاليا
يتحدث عن منافسه تجري في المرحله المقبله
ما شكل هذه المنافسه سيد
اعتقد ان وزير الخراجيه محق نعم هنالك
منافسه واعتقد ان القياده الصينيه تشعر
بنفس الشيء ونحن ليس لدينا مانع من
المنافسه المنافسه هي ممكن ان تكون في
الاقتصاد والتجاره وايضا المنافسه تظهر
وهنالك طرق مختلفه للحكم هنالك المقاربه
الصينيه وهنالك المقاربه الامريكيه
والغربيه بالتالي هنالك
يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال مع السيد جيم
تاونزن اعود اليك سيد رون وان
ما توقعات الصينيه بشان هذه المنافسه التي
يجري الحديث عنها امريكيا من اجل تشكل
ملامح المرحله المقبله
الصين يعني
للمنافسه ان يجب ان تكون هذه المنافسه
منافسه شريفه يمكن ان يحقق المكاسب او فوز
المشتركه من خلال التعاون للكلى الطرفين
وليس يعني هو سباق الى الامام وليس السباق
على احتواء الاخر او ضرب الاخر
فالتقدم المشتركه وحدث هذا هذه المنافسه
وثم كذلك هذه المنافسه يجب ان يكونوا يعني
التنميه السلميه وكذلك يعني تجنب من
الصراع المفتوحه بين البلدين وهو بمعنى
اداره الخلافات بشكل جيد لكن التصريحات
الروسيه لا تعكس هذه الرؤيه اليوم
ديمتريديف يتحدث عن ان هناك دولا لا تفهم
لغه القوه ويقول ان العقد المقبل لن يكون
هادئا هل تشارك الصين هذه النظره للامور
قد طبعا يعني لا يجب ان تكونوا العلاقه
يعني
بين دول الكبرى مثل العلاقات في احد في
فتره بين دول الكبرى في فتره الحرب
البارده
الصين تتمسك بمبدا وعدم من انحياز وكذلك
عدم
الاستهداف الطرف الثالث
فكما وصفت الصين الاعلام او الشراكه بين
الصين وروسيا تجاوزت العلاقات بين الدول
والتحالفات العسكريه السياسيه في الفترات
الحرب البارده وهذا هذه العلاقه تكون على
اساس الاحترام المتبادل وتعايش السلمي
وفوز المشتركه
وتعاون وهذه العلاقه
قدوه للتعامل بين الدول الكبرى
والصناعه ايضا حتى بين
الولايات المتحده ان يجب ان تكونوا على
هذا هذه المبادئ من اجل بناء مجتمع مصير
المشتركه للبشريه وليس الانقسام
نظره الصينيه ولكن كيف ستتعامل الصين وهي
في هذه المرحله من التقارب الكبير مع
روسيا مع النظره الروسيه الذي يبدو انها
مختلفه تماما حياه مقاربه الامور كما ذكرت
لك تصريحات ان بعض الدول لا تفهم الى لغه
القوه
هناك مواقف متشابهه بين الصين وروسيا
فهنا
بمعنى ان الصين ايضا يعني لا تقبل بان
هناك استفزازات او تحديدات
للصين
باستخدام القوه
فنحن الى الان لا يمكن تحديد التنمر على
سين او على روسيا باستخدام القوه لان يعني
قد انتهت الزمن التي يمكن ان يسيطر الدول
على اخرى باستخدام قوه فقط اشكرك السيد
رونو الاعلامي والباحث السياسي للبيجين
وشكر موصول لسيد جيم تاون النائب مساعد
وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق لشؤون اوروبا
والذي كان ضيفنا من باريس ليعكس وجهه
النظر الامريكيه في هذا الحوار حاولنا
اعاده الاتصال به للاسف لم نوفق نشكره على
اي حال بعد فتره قصيره اذا على اعلان
الولايات المتحده انها بصدد احاله طائره
اي عشره الهجوميه الى التقاعد عادت لتؤكد
انه سيتم نشرها بالشرق الاوسط مقابل
ارساله مقاتلات حديثه باتجاه اسيا واوروبا
ياتي هذا في اطار توجه واشنطن الجديد الذي
تحدثت عنه صحيفه
اكثر على التنافس الاستراتيجي وتحجيم
النفوذ الصينيه الروسي في العالم
حضور متواضع في الشرق الاوسط وتركيز اكبر
على المخاطر القادمه من الصين وروسيا في
هذا السياق تاتيه خطه الولايات المتحده
الراميه الى نقل مقاتلات حديثه من الشرق
الاوسط الى منطقتي اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
واوروبا واستبدالها بطائرات اي 10
الهجوميه القديمه
بحسب مسؤولين امريكيين فان الخطوه المقرره
تنفيذها في ابريل المقبل هي جزء من خطه
اوسع تنص على الاحتفاظ بقوات بحريه وبريه
متواضعه في الشرق الاوسط بينما ياتي نقل
المقاتلات الاكثر تطورا الى اوروبا واسيا
ضمن جهود واشنطن لردع بيجين وموسكو فالصين
في عرف البنتاجون هي الخطر الاكبر حاليا
بينما يتواصل القلق من تداعيات الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا
هي طائره هجوم امريكيه دشنت في سبعينيات
القرن الماضي متخصصه في الاسناد القتالي
وتستخدم في تدمير الدبابات وغيرها من
المركبات المدرعه سلاحها
الاساسيينج وهو عباره عن رشاش دوار ثقيل
يطلق اربعه الاف طلقه في الدقيقه كما
يمكنها استخدام ذخائر عاليه الدقه واسلحه
موجهه بالليزر مغلفه بدرع من التيتانيوم
لحمايه الطيار وهي قادره على الاستمرار
بالطيران حتى لو فقدت احد اجنحتها يبلغ
طول الطائره نحو 16 مترا وربع المتر
وارتفاعها نحو اربعه امتار ونصف ويزيد
وزنها على 22 طنا اما سرعتها القصوى فتصل
لنحو 830 كيلومترا في الساعه لكن رغم انها
تعد اليوم بطيئه وضعيفه وغير قادره على
التعامل القدرات الجيش الصيني المتناميه
فان الخبراء الامريكيين يرون انه لا يزال
لديها فائده في الشرق الاوسط
لاستخدامها ضد الميليشيات المسلحه باسلحه
خفيفه وهذا سيمكن البنتاجون من نقل
المقاتلات الحديثه متعدده المهام الى
المحيط الهادئ واوروبا
[موسيقى]
من الكويت ينضم الينا الدكتور عبد الله
الشايجي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
الكويت مرحبا بك دكتور عبد الله عالم ما
بعد الحرب البارده اذا انتهى كما يقول
انتوني بلينكن ما ملامح المرحله المقبله
طبعا على ما بعد الحرب البارده امريكا
تتكلم عنها منذ عقد تقريبا من الزمن ان
هناك في قوه صاعده ان التقارير التي
تصدرها سنويا اجهزه الاستخبارات الامريكيه
تؤكد ان هناك تعدديه قطبيه قادمه هناك
صراع يعني تبدو بوادره واضحه منذ 2014
عندما تجرا بوتين واحتل شبه جزيره القرم
ثم تجرا اكثر واحتل الان اجزاء من
اوكرانيا للشهر الثالث عشر حرب مفتوحه في
اوكرانيا يتحدى فيها ادنيتو والغرب ويغير
حدود اوروبا
التاريخيه جغرافيا بعد 78 سنه من نهايه
الحرب البارده ينضم لذلك التحالف الصيني
وراينا الزياره التي قام بها قبل ايام
الرئيس شيتش الى روسيا وهذا تحالف يعني
يقترب من التحالف الاستراتيجي وايضا الصين
لديها طموح بان تحاصر امريكا وتمنعها من
التدخل في شؤونها ولهذا السبب ما ذكره
يعني حتى وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي بلينكن لجلسه لمجلس الشيوخ لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه وخاصه رد السنه روبيو
الجمهوري يؤكد اننا نحن مقبلين على العقد
القادم عقل ما عقد ما يسمى اي الصراع او
النزاع خاصه بتحالف الصين مع روسيا وقوه
اخرى مواليه لروسيا والصين في مناطق نفوذ
ككوريا الشماليه كايران ودول اخرى قد تنضم
مثل نيكاراغوا وغيرها من الدول ولهذا
السبب هناك بالفعل الان مواجهه قادمه جراه
عند الصين الصين يعني بذكاء وبتروي وبسمى
يتحدث عن مواجهه المتهوره والولايات
المتحده تتحدث عن منافسه استراتيجيه
وبالتالي ماذا نتوقع في المرحله المقبله
في هذا الاطار
نتوقع الصين ستتجرا اكثر الان الصين عندها
ثاني اكبر ميزانيه دفاع بعد امريكا تقترب
من 300 مليار دولار امريكي اكثر من 800
مليار دولار نتوقع ان الصين الان تتدخل في
شؤون لم تكن تتدخل فيها الان تيك توك يعني
اليوم اتابع في الكونغرس الامريكي يستجوب
لمدير التنفيذي لشركه تيك توك يعني امريكا
تقول ان حتى تيك توك القهوه الناعمه
الصينيه عندها مليار مشترك في العالم من
150 مليون منهم في امريكا تتجسس تتدخل
عندها الحزب الشيوعي الصيني بيانات
للامريكان
عن ما يقومون به ولهذا السبب المعركه
القادمه او المواجهه القادمه هي مواجهه
متعدده الرؤوس والابعاد الصين مستعده لها
ولكن تحالفها مع روسيا هو المقلق الان
بوتين يتصرف بتهور الصين تتصرف بتروي
وباستراتيجيه وتكتيك الصين تريد ان تستعيد
تايوان ولكن الان عن كثب العقوبات وما
تقوم به امريكا من عقوبات مع اوروبا ضد
روسيا روسيا دوله عظمى معزوله الصين دوله
عظمى تتوسع بثقه وبهدوء وشفنا ايضا نجاحها
في الوصفات بين السعوديه وايران في عقر
هذه الوساطه دكتور عبد الله وذكر الشرق
الاوسط اليوم جراء الحديث عن نقل مقاتلات
امريكيه من الشرق الاوسط الى اسيا واوروبا
ما دلالاتها في الخطوه باعتقادك
دلالات ان الاولويه عند امريكا الان منذ
عهد اوباما لما ذكر ب 2011-2012
الاستداره شرقا ان امريكا ملت من الحروف
في الشرق الاوسط مرت من الوجود العسكري
المكلف والباهر في افغانستان سحبت العراق
خفضت القوات سوريا خفض القوات الاولويه
حسب تقوله يعني مذكرات الامن الوطني
الامريكي ومذكره الدفاع الامريكي التي
صدرت في اكتوبر الماضي ان الاولويه
لمواجهه الصين والتصدي للمغامرات الروسيه
فالوليه لم تعد في الخليج لم تعد محاربه
الارهاب في الاستراتيجيه العسكريه
والامنيه الامريكيه بل التوجه شرقا منذ
2011 منذ ايام اوباما الذي فشل بالتحرك
شرقا بسبب العراق وافغانستان ولكن الان
المواجهه واضحه يعني حتى امريكا انشات
تحالفات تزعج الصين يعني ايكيوس التحالف
الانجلوس
قبل سنه ونصف بين امريكا
واستراليا وبريطانيا والذي ضرب فرنسا
بغواصات نوويه لاستراليا التحالف
الكوادر الرباعي الذي فيه امريكا
واستراليا
واليابان والهند حتى الصين تشعر بانها
محاصره من امريكا وتريد ان تثبت الامريكا
والنظام العالمي انها قطب قادم وعلى
الجميع ان يحترمها اشكرك من الكويت
الدكتور عبد الله الشايجي استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الكويت
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان البنتاجون
شكل فريقا للتاكد من تسريع عمليه تسليم
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا وتزويتها بالقدرات
اللازمه من جانبه قال الامين العام للنيتو
انه سيتعين على الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا وفرنسا والمانيا والدول الغربيه
الاخرى الاستعداد لدعم اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
والذخيره وقطع الغيار لفتره طويله وفي
حوار مع صحيفه الجارديان اكد صوتن ان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لا يخطط
للتوصل الى سلام بل لمزيد من الحروب وكشف
الصوت ان روسيا تعزز من الانتاج الصناعي
العسكري كما تتواصل مع ما وصفها بالانظمه
السلطويه للحصول على مزيد من الاسلحه
في هذه الاثناء نشرت السلطات العسكريه
النرويجيه صور ارسال ثماني دبابات اثنين
وذخائر عسكريه اخرى الى اوكرانيا وقالت
القوات المسلحه النرويجيه انها تقوم
بتدريب الجنود الاوكرانيين على استخدام
الدبابات في بولندا ياتي هذا التسليم ضمن
ما يعرف بتحالف الدبابات داخل النيتو ويضم
ويضم بالاضافه الى النرويج المانيا
وبولندا والبرتغال وكندا لارسال ثمان
واربعين دبابه ليبرد اثنين الى اوكرانيا
بدورها اعلنت وزاره الدفاع سلوفاكيا تسليم
اول اربع طائرات مقاتله من طراز ميج 29
الى اوكرانيا واضافت وزاره الدفاع
سلوفاكيه ان طائرات اخرى ستسلم الى
اوكرانيا في الاسابيع المقبله
في المقابل حذر نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي من تداعيات الاستمرار في امداد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه وقال ان ذلك يزيد من
خطر اندلاعي حرب نوويه
هل انتهى خطر الحرب النوويه لا لم ينتهي
بل ازداد توريد السلاح الى اوكرانيا كل
يوم يقربنا في نهايه المطاف من نهايه عالم
نوويه
[موسيقى]
تظاهر انصار المعارضه في اسرائيل في
احتجاجات متواصله على تعديلات التي ادخلها
الائتلاف الحاكم على النظام القضائي والتي
ترى فيها المعارضه خطرا سيحول اسرائيل الى
ما وصفوها بدكتاتوريه دينيه واعتقلت
الشرطه الاسرائيليه اثني عشر شخصا بينما
بدا متظاهرون في التجمع وسط تل ابيب
واغلقوا شوارع فرعيه وقد كفت السلطات
الامنيه من حضورها لكن ذلك لم يمنع
المتظاهرين من اغلاق شارع ايالون الرئيسي
الذي يربط تل ابيب بالقدس كما استخدمت
الشرطه فرق الخياله لتفريق المتظاهرين
ومنعهم من الوصول الى الشارع الرئيسي
وحاول المتظاهرون اغلاق شوارع رئيسيه في
مدن اخرى مثل القدس وحيفا الا ان الشرطه
فرقتهم
وعلى الرغم من هذه الاحتجاجات المستمره
منذ اسابيع صدقت الهيئه العامه للكنيسه
الاسرائيلي صباحا اليوم على مشروع قانون
يشدد من شروط عزل رئيس الحكومه او اعلان
عجزه عن القيام بمهامه ويمنح القانون
والحصانه لبنيامين نتنياهو الذي يحاكم
بتهم الفساد وخيانه الامانه وقد صوت
لمشروع القانون 61 نائبا وعرضه سبعه
واربعون
وقال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو انه يعتزم المضي قدما في اصلاحات
قضائيه مسؤوله حسب وصفه معتبرا ان
الاصلاحات القضائيه ستوازن بين السلطات
وستحافظ على حقوق الاقليه واتهم نتنياهو
ممثلين معارضه برفض الدخول في مفاوضات منذ
اشهر
ان الطريقه الامثل لتحقيق الاصلاحات
المتوازنه ومنع الشرخ في اوساط الشعب هي
المباحثات والتواصل الى توافق واسع قدر
الامكان للاسف حتى الان ممثل المعارضه
رفضوا الجلوس معنا واجراء مباحثات لقد تمت
اضاعه اربعه اشهر تقريبا امل ان يتغير ذلك
وان يتغير ذلك في الايام القادمه انا اعمل
من اجل تحقيق حل وانا اصغي لمخاوف الطرف
الاخر
اضاف نتنياهو ان الدعوات لعصيان الاوامر
العسكريه تشكل خطرا على الامن القومي
لاسرائيل وعلى الامن الشخصي للافرادي كذلك
ويجب ان تتوقف وفق تعبيره
اجتمعت اليوم مع عدد من الوزراء منهم وزير
الدفاع واستمعت اليه فيما يتعلق بالمخاوف
وتداعيات الوضع على الامن القومي لاسرائيل
انا اخذ ذلك بعين الاعتبار وفي ان معا اجد
لزاما علي ان اكرر مره اخرى الا مجال
لعصيان الاوامر العسكريه العصيان يشكل
خطرا على الامن القومي الاسرائيلي وعلى
الامن الشخصي لكل فرد منا ولا يوجد مبرر
للعصيان سوف ابذل كل ما في وسعي من اجل
تهدئه الخواطر والتئام الشرخ بين مكونات
الشعب لاننا اخوه
هذا وقال رئيس الشباك ان اسرائيل تمضي في
طريق خطير للغايه بوجود تهديدات الامنيه
وتواصل الاحتجاجات الشعبيه حديث ياتي بعد
اتهام زعيم المعارضه
ومعلومات استخباريه مهمه وصلت الى مكتبه
دعا في تغ على تويتر للاستماع لاصوات مئات
الالاف ممن وصفهم بالوطنيين المخلصين
الذين نزلوا للشوارع اضاف انه بدلا من وقف
التشريع وتهدئه الاجواء يستمرون نتنياهو
في نشر ما وصفها باكاذيب الشائله ضد نظام
العداله التي لا علاقه لها بالواقع بحسب
تعبيره كما طالب لبيد قاده في الحزب
الحاكم بالانشقاق
من القدس معنا مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
الياس دعن في صوره هذا السجال الدائر بين
نتنياهو المعارضه من جهه وبين مكونات
الحكومه نفسها ايضا
اليوم بني مريتانيا يشعر نفسه بانه اصبح
اكثر قوه لاداره دفه هذه الاصلاحات لاسيما
وانه ممنوع بقرار من المستشار القضائيه
للحكومه بالتدخل بهذه الاصلاحات القضائيه
على ضوء ما يلاحقه من تهم فساد لكن بعد
التحصين نفسه والتعديلات التي ادخلها على
هذا القانون يقول بانه هو الان سيدخل بقوه
على خط هذه المواجهه ما بين المعارضه
والائتلاف الحاكم في كل ما يتعلق بهذه
الاصلاحات القضائيه وهو من يدير امورها
وهو يؤكد بان حكومته ماضيه في هذه
الاصلاحات رغم كل هذه الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
في اسرائيل وان هذه
الاصلاحات هدفها احداث التوازن ما بين
السلطات في اسرائيل وهو يقول بانه سيسعى
الى تحصين حقوق الاقليه في اسرائيل ضمن
هذه الاصلاحات
في تشريع ربما احق احد اهم البنود في هذه
الاصلاحات كما يسميها او التغييرات التي
تقول المعارضه بانها انقلاب على نظام
الحكم في اسرائيل وهي التعديلات التي يريد
نتنياهو ادخالها في لجنه تعيين القضاه
بحيث تكون الغلبه في بين اعضائها لصالح
الائتلاب بمعنى ان هذه اللجنه سوف تكون
لجنه مسيسه وتابعه للحكومه الاسرائيليه
وهذا ما ترفضه المعارضه جمله وتفصيرا لكن
من يمينه يقول بان هذا القانون سيطره على
الكنيسه الاسبوع المقبل وسيجري التصويت
عليه وهو يقول بانه يفتح الباب على
مصراعيه في المحاكم امام شرائح مختلفه في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي كانت ابواب المحاكم
مغلقه وموصده في في وجههم لكن من ناحيه
اخرى المعارضه تقول بان هذه اكاذيب لا
تنطلي عليهم هم يريدون اولا ان توقف
الحكومه الاسرائيليه على الفور كل
الاجراءات التشريعيه في الكنيست من اجل
الجلوس على طاوله المفاوضات وربما البحث
عن ما هو يمكن التوفيق ما بين الطرفين وان
كانت
الطريق بعيده والاراء والمواقف متباعده
للغايه ما بين الائتلاف والمعارضه في
رؤيتهم لهذه التغييرات ولهذه الاصلاحات
وهناك من يقول انه من المستحيل ان يلتقي
الطرفان على في منتصف الطريق على الاقل من
اجل التوصل الى تسويه تكون مرضيه للطرفين
لاسيما بعد ان رفضت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
منحى الرئيس الاسرائيلي الذي حاول ان يقرب
وجهات النظر بين الطرفين شكرا لك
مراسلنا من القدس
معنا من حيث جاكي خوري الكاتب المختص في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه سيد جاكي ماذا ستكون
عليه تداعيات اصرار نتنياهو على المضي
قدما بالاصلاحات القضائيه وهذا القانون
الذي جرسنه اليوم
بتصعيد اقاله رئيس الحكومه في ظل الحركه
الاحتجاجيه المتواصله
مساء الخير لك وللمشاهدين اعتقد ان الخطوه
القادمه ستكون في مسارين اساسيين واضح ان
خطاب نتنياه وكلمه نتنياهو هذا المساء
شكلت جرعه يعني دعم للمحتجين تحديدا لان
البعض اعتقد انه في ظل التهديدات الامنيه
والرسائل الامنيه التي وصلت بشكل مباشر
لنتنيورو من قبل وزير الامن يعرف ومن قمه
القاده الاجهزه الامنيه اذا كانوا من
يعملون الان او ممن كانوا في السابق بان
هذا سيغير من موقفه تجاه هذه الخطه
للسيطره على جهاز القضاء ولكن
واضحا هذا المساء انه ماض في مساره رغمى
كل يعني الكلمات الملمقه ومحاوله تغليف
يعني بعض الامور المتعلقه بالحوار مع
الاطراف المعارضه نتنياهو يصر على تمرير
هذه الخطه واعتقد عندما ياتي خطاب بهذا
التوقيت وبهذا الساعه وبعد ذلك يغادر
نهايه اسبوع في لندن هذا فقط سيزيد من
يعني ضغط الشارع وايضا ضغط المحتجين عليه
وعلى اقطاب في حكومته وفي اتلافه وبالتالي
اتوقع انه خلال الايام القريبه القادمه
خاصه يوم السبت مساء رغم احوال الطقس
الماطره كما يتوقعون هنا سيخرج عشرات
الالاف من الشارع وايضا سنكون امام مشهد
لربما في الاسبوع القادم بالشكل الاخطر
واكبر ونحن نقترب من لحظه الحسم بالنسبه
لاقرار القوانين قبل ان تخرج الكنيست او
البرلمان اللي اجازتها وطبعا هنالك مسار
اخر وتحرك المؤسسه الامنيه بشكل مباشر
وعلني امام نتنياهو في محاوله لوقف هذا
التصعيد الحاصل داخلي تحرك للمؤسسه
الامنيه تحذيرات من رئيس الشباب وكذلك
يبدو ان هناك خلاف جد يناسب مع وزير
الدفاع في داخل الحكومه كيف يمكن ان يتطور
هذا وينعكس على الائتلاف الحكومي
المساحه الاقليميه والعربيه وهذا ما
يحاولون ايصال الان داخل المؤسسه الامنيه
والعسكريه لنتنياهو لا توجد تهديدات
مباشره في الاقليم لربما حتى لو كان هنالك
ما يعرف الان بتهديد ايراني ولكن هنالك
تحركات اقليميه تستوجب عمليا ضبط الامور
داخليا وهذا ما لا يحدث حتى شكرا لك
الكاتب المختص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه من
حيفا
ياتي مشهد الحكومه الاسرائيليه المتازم مع
استمرار تصعيدها في الضفه الغربيه حيث شيع
الفلسطينيون اليوم الشهيد امير ابو خديجه
الذي قتلته قوات الاحتلال فجر الخميس في
مدينه طولكرم شمال الضفه الغربيه وقال
نادي الاسير الفلسطيني ان قوات الاحتلال
اعتقل تسعه فلسطينيين على الاقل في انحاء
متفرقه من الضفه الغربيه فجر اليوم الى
ذلك قالت وزيره الدوله في الخارجيه
البريطانيه ان
امام جلسه لمجلس العموم ان الغاء اسرائيل
لقرار فك الارتباط في فلسطين يلحق الضرر
بمشروع حل الدولتين
ان تخرج الاداره الامريكيه عن صمتها ازاء
ممارسات اسرائيل ضد الفلسطينيين فذلك يعني
ان الحليف الوثيق لواشنطن تخطى حدود ما
يمكن تفهمه او تحمله لكن ورغم الخطوه
النادره باستدعاء الخارجيه الامريكيه
للسفير الاسرائيلي وتحذيره من مخاطر
التصعيد فان الاحتلال يمضي قدما في
اجراءاته على الارض وعلى صعيد التصريحات
السياسيه هذه جنازه الشهيد امير عماد ابو
خديجه قائد مجموعه الرد السريع كتيبه
طولكرم الذي اغتالته قوات الاحتلال يوم
الخميس في مدينه طولكرم شمال الضفه
الغربيه الاغتيال الجديد يندرج ضمن حمله
التصعيد الاسرائيلي المستمر من اقتحامات
للمدن والبلدات الغربيه
امنيات الضفه في اول ايام شهر رمضان سجلت
ايضا عمليات اعتقال اسرائيليه في طول كرم
اخرى اذ اكد نادي الاسير الفلسطيني ان
الاعتقالات تمت في الخليل ونابلس وبيت لحم
ورام الله وجنين حيث دهمت قوه عسكريه من
جيش الاحتلال عددا من منازل الفلسطينيين
وعبثت بمحتوياتها قبل اقتيادها الموقوفين
الى مراكز للتحقيق معهم بتهمه مقاومه
الاحتلال ولا يزال التصعيد الاسرائيلي في
مرمى الانتقادات الدوليه لا سيما بعد
اقرار الكنيست قانونا يسمح للمستوطنين
بالعوده الى اربع مستوطنات في الضفه
الغربيه اخليت عام 2005 وهي جانيم وكاديم
وحوميش وسنور
نشعر بقلق عميق ازاء الالغاء الاخير
لقانون فك الارتباط لعام 2005 من طرف
الكنيست هذا القرار هو اجراء اخر احادي
الجانب يضر باي جهود متجدده لخفض التصعيد
ويقوض حل الدولتين
قبل ذلك شجب مجلس الامن الدولي تصعيد
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والتوسع الاستيطاني
في الضفه وبناء وحدات سكنيه جديده في
مستوطنات قائمه وحذر مندوب الدول الاعضاء
من التداعيات الخطيره لتلك الافعال على
الامن والسلم وعلى حل الدولتين الذي يقره
المجتمع الدولي
[موسيقى]
الى فرنسا حيث شهدت العاصمه باريس ومدن
اخرى مظاهرات حاشده تزامنا مع اضرابات
شامله في قطاعات عده بين الطيران والنقل
والمحروقات ضمن موجه الاحتجاجات المناهضه
لقانون تعديل نظام التقاعد وقد اطلقت
النقابات على حشد اليوم اسم الخميس الاسود
رفضا من القانون الذي مررته الحكومه دون
تصويت برلماني باللجوء الى ماده دستوريه
سمحت لها بذلك وتنظم هذه المظاهرات وسط
تعبئه امنيه واسعه يشارك فيها نحو اثني
عشر الف رجل امن في كامل فرنسا بينهم خمسه
الاف شرطي في العاصمه وحدها لمواجهه
المحتجين
وضمن تحركات الاحتجاجيه قام نشاطا نقابيون
بقطع شبكه السكك الحديديه في محطه قطارات
ليون بالعاصمه او جنوب العاصمه باريس كما
اغلق نحو 70 موظفا فرنسيا الطريق المؤدي
الى مطار شارلدغول شماليه باريس مطوره بعض
المسافرين للوصول الى هناك سيرا على
الاقدام غير ان السلطات المطار قالت ان
هذا العمل الاحتجاجي لا يؤثر على الرحلات
الجويه
وكان الرئيس الفرنسي امانويل ماكرون قد
علق على الاحتجاجات بالتاكيد على انه لن
يسمح باي جروح للعنف وشدد على ضروره دخول
القانون حيز التنفيذ قبل نهايه العام
الجاري داعيا النقابات للعوده الى الحوار
من باريس معنا
استاذه العلوم السياسيه وعلم الاجتماع في
كليه كيدجال الاعمال سيده فيرجيني من الذي
سيتراجع للاخر الحكومه ام المحتجين
هذا السؤال صعب جدا في الواقع يمكن ان
نفكر بان الحكومه لا ترغب اطلاقا بالتراجع
وكذلك سعر القول المحتجون ايضا لا يريدون
التراجع اطلاقا وبالتالي هذه مواجهه في
الحقيقه كانها ظهرا الى ظهر هناك
تنافس
ومصادمات كثيره قويه واعتقد ان النتيجه قد
تاتي او الحل قد ياتي من مجلس الدستوري
ما حجم
اذا الحل من المجلس الدستوري على اي شكل
الو بتكون
كيف يكون الحال لان المجلس الدستوري لديه
شهر ليقرر خل ان هذا القانون يتطابق مع
بنود الدستور انه اتخذ ضمن عمليه
ديمقراطيه سليمه وعمليه تشريعيه سليمه هذا
هو يجب او ما يجب ان يقرره المجلس
الدستوري وبالتالي قد يمكن يقول ان وسيله
او الطريقه التشريعيه التي
صارت عليه الحكومه لم تكن صحيحه ربما
وبالتالي هذا الموضوع الى المناقشه لو ان
هذا القرار اتى لمصلحه الحكومه هل سيعود
المحتاجون الى بيوتهم باعتقادك ويقبلون
بهذا التشريع الجديد
لنقل انه بعد ان
اذا ما وافق
المجلس على ما فعلت الحكمون فانه قد تكون
قد دعوه لاجراء استفتاء ولكن هذه عمليه
طويله ومعقده جدا وبالتالي يمكن تسيطر
الحكومه على الوضع مره اخرى الكثير من
الناس يعتقدون ان هذا الاستفتاء قد يكون
هو طريقه للخروج من هذا المازقه والازمه
اشكرك السيده فيرجيني مارتا استاذه العلوم
السياسيه وعلم الاجتماع في كليه كيدج
للاعمال ضيفتنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
مثل المدير التنفيذي لشركه تيك توك زوشي
تشاو امام لجنه الطاقه والتجاره في مجلس
النواب وسط دعوات لمنع تطبيق تيك توك في
الولايات المتحده ياتي ذلك مع دعوه من
الاداره الامريكيه لفصل تطبيق تيك توك
المستخدم من قبل نحو 150 مليون امريكي عن
الشركه المالكه له بايت دانس
من الاسئله والاتهامات واجهت المدير
التنفيذي لشركه تيك توك شوزي شو لدى مثوله
امام الكونجرس مشرع الحزبين اعربوا عن
شكوكهم في استقلاليه التطبيق عن الحكومه
الصينيه
الامريكيه بالحريه وحقوق الانسان
والابتكار تيك توك تبنت مرارا مسار المزيد
من السيطره والمراقبه والتلاعب يجب منع
تطبيقكم واتوقع ان تقول اي شيء لتفادي هذه
النتيجه
تيك توك عن الحكومه الصينيه ليقدم تطمينات
بان معلومات المستخدمين ستكون تحت حمايه
القانون الامريكي هذا العام
اتعهد بالالتزامات الاتيه تجاهكم وتجاه
جميع مستخدمينه اولا ستكون السلامه وبخاصه
للمراهقين اولويه قصوى بالنسبه لنا ثانيا
سنعزز جدار الحمايه للبيانات من الوصول
الاجنبي غير المرغوب فيه ثالثا سيبقى تيك
توك مكانا لحريه التعبير ولن يجري التلاعب
به من اي حكومه ورابعا سنتحلى بالشفافيه
وسنمنح مراقبين مستقلين تابعين لجهات
خارجيه حق الاطلاع لنبقى مسؤولين عن
التزاماتنا
النائب الديمقراطي جمال دافع عن تيك توك
متسائلا عن جدوى منع تطبيق يستخدمه 150
مليون امريكي وتداعيات ذلك على صانعي
المحتوى قد يغيب الاجماع بشان ما قد يتخذ
من خطوات تمس مستقبل تيك توك في الولايات
المتحده لكن مشرعي الحزبين يتفقون في غياب
ثقتهم بالتطبيق شهاده المدير التنفيذي
لتيك توك كما المح غالبهم لم توفر تطمينات
بل زادت من اسئلتهم بسبب كويك الجزيره
واشنطن
[موسيقى]
يتعرض اذا تطبيق تيك توك الذي تملكه شركه
بايت دانس الصينيه لتهديدا كبيرا من
الولايات المتحده بمنعه خصوصا بعد تخيير
اداره الرئيس جو بايدن للشركه بين ان
تتخلى عن ملكيتها الصينيه او تواجه حظرا
تاما كاغلب المنصات الاجتماعيه المملوكه
للولايات المتحده يوتيوب وفيسبوك
وانستجرام يجمع تطبيق تيك توك جميع انواع
البيانات عن كل مستخدم ومن خلال
خوارزمياته يستخدم بل يستخدم هذه
المعلومات لعرض مزيدا من الامور التي تهم
المستخدمين ولكن ينظر الى التطبيق على انه
الاكثر تقدما والاكثر فعاليه بشكل غير
متوقع في التعرف على اهتمامات المستخدمين
شركه تيك توك الصينيه مثيره للقلق بشكل
خاص في الولايات المتحده حيث يقضي التطبيق
الامريكيون سته وخمسين دقيقه في المتوسط
يوميا عليه اي اكثر بكثير مما يقضونه على
فيسبوك او انستجرام يتخوف منتقدون تيك توك
من امكانيه تسريب بيانات مستخدمي تطبيق في
الولايات المتحده الى الحكومه الصينيه
وتقول واشنطن ان هذه البيانات قد تستخدم
بهدف التجسس على الامريكيين او لنشر
الدعايه اداره التطبيق اعلنت انها انفقت
اكثر من مليار ونصف المليار دولار على ما
تسميه الجهود الصارمه لامن البيانات تحت
اسم مشروع تكساس وتصر تيك توك على ان
تطبيق لا يعمل بشكل مختلف عن منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي الاخرى وتقول انها لن
تمتثل اطلاقا لاي امر بنقل البيانات الى
سلطات بيجين ان طلب من ذلك
ينضم الينا اذا الان من واشنطن جودي ويسبي
مديره شركه المخاطر الدوليه للانترنت
والامن السيبراني سيده جودي مرحبا بك هل
تتجه السلطات الامريكيه الى حظر التطبيق
فعلا
يا نعم نعم اعتقد ان الكونجرس بالاضافه
الى البيت
يتجهون نحو فرضي حظر لا اعتقد ان جلسه
الاستماع قد غيرت من موقفهم او رايهم لكن
هل يمكن بالفعل فرض هذا الحظر
نعم نعم نحن
قمنا بفرض اظن على استخدام هذا التطبيق من
قبل
الموظفين وايضا العديد من الولايات قامت
بذلك وكندا ايضا قامت بنفس الامر بالتالي
باستطاعتنا ان نقول ان هذا التطبيق يمكن
ان يكون محظورا في الولايات المتحده هذا
التطبيق محظور في الصين هو ليس متوفر
للاستخدام في الصين ده في داخل الصين
وعليه ماذا سيكون باعتقادك
مستقبل تيك توك ما هو مصير هذا التطبيق
الذي يحظى بكل هذه الجماهيريه الواسعه حول
العالم
هو يتمتع بشعبيه كبيره لكن اعتقد انه اما
عليه ان يقوم
يقوم باجراء تعديلات ربما او ربما لن يتم
سماح باستخدامه في الولايات المتحده
الضمانات
السياسه التي يتبعها لم تطمن تطمن الساسه
كانوا كم يطلبوا البيانات المستخدمين
السلطات الصينيه لكن حسب سياسات التطبيق
فان الشركات عليها ان تتعاون مع الحكومات
الحكومات التي التي ياتي منها التطبيق
وبالتالي ربما بوبيت قد يحل محل تيك توك
او ربما قد يكون هنالك ربما تعديل في
السياسه لكن اعتقد انه سيكون هنالك مع ذلك
بعض الق المفروض عليه ما لم يتم تغيير
السياسه الحقيقيه له لماذا لم تقتنع
السلطات الامريكيه بما قاله رئيس مجلس
اداره تيك توك بانه لن يجري باي حال من
الاحوال مشاركه البيانات لدى التطبيق مع
السلطات الصينيه
كما تعرفون اعتقد ان الكونجرس بدا يفهم
قوه هذا هذه البيانات التي يستخدمها من
130 مليون امريكي والذي والذي تكشفه هويه
اجهزتهم ما يفضلون وكل شيء يستمعون له
وهوياتهم الكونغرس بداوا بداوا يفهمون قوه
اللوغاريتمات في ربما
تغذيه نوع من القصص او المعلومات لكنها قد
تعطي جانبا واحد من قصه ما اعتقد كذلك ان
الكونجرس بدا ان حملات تشويه المعلومات
بامكانها ان تعمل وتكون ناشطه في تيك توك
وفي منصات اخرى وعندما يكون لدينا مثل هذا
التجمع الكبير من البيانات الخاصه
بالسكان الامريكيين هذا يعتبر اداء قويه
بامكانها قد يسااء من قبل حكومه اجنبيه
بالتالي هذا التمييز بين التطبيقات الاخرى
مثل فيسبوك او تطبيقات اخرى والتي لها
قواعد هنا في الولايات المتحده بالتالي
ليس لديهم مشكله في تسليم هذه البيانات
الى الحكومه الامريكيه طيب هذا التطبيق
يستخدمه اكثر من 150 مليون امريكي يقدون
الدقائق كثيره عليه خلال اليوم اكثر من ما
يقضونه على باقي التطبيقات بالتالي هذا
يشكل اقتصادا بحد ذاته جرى حظر هذا
التطبيق ما هو مصير هذا الاقتصاد الدائر
على تيك توك
عليهم اما ان يقوموا
ربما اجراء تعديلات او انه قد يكون ذلك
تطبيقات منافسه تحل محل اعتقد ان ما سيحدث
انه
قد يكون
هنالك هنالك نقطه علينا ان نحذر منها لان
الحكومه الصينيه ربما تخبر تخبرهم انهم لا
يمكنهم ان يكون هذا الامر
ممكنا وبالتالي قد يحدث نوعا من المواجهه
بين الحكومه الامريكيه والحكومه الصينيه
شكرا لك من واشنطن
مديره شركه المخاطر الدوليه للانترنت
والامن
بهذا المشاهدينا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد
لهذه الليله شكرا لمتابعتكم وتصبحون على
خير
[موسيقى]